the word that you need to look for is
chaos if what you're doing is causing
chaos you are going to be part of the
problem so here we are on the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special with Glenn
Beck and when we get into his new book
addicted to outrage in just one second
but first let's talk about your data
security whether you're in a cafe or a
hotel we often rely on public Wi-Fi to
use the internet on the go but something
as simple as paying your bills online
from a Starbucks could leave your data
exposed a hacker can easily intercept
your information steal passwords credit
cards personal details it's not just
hackers government agencies like the NSA
monitor the entire internet may be
scooping up your activity so what can
you do to defend yourself the software I
used to protect my online activity from
spies and data thieves it's called
expressvpn Express BPM has easy-to-use
apps that run seamlessly in the
background of my computer phone and
tablet expressvpn secures and anonymizes
my internet browsing by encrypting my
data hiding my public IP address using
expressvpn I can safely surf on public
Wi-Fi without being snooped on or having
my personal data stolen for best
protection I recommend using expressvpn
every time you go online Express VPN
cost less than seven bucks a month comes
with a 30-day money-back guarantee to
take back your internet privacy today
and find out how you can get three
months for free go to expressvpn comm
slash Ben that's expr ESS VPN comm slash
been for three months free with a
one-year package get expressvpn secure
internet now again that's expressvpn
comm slash Ben to learn more Glenn Beck
thanks for stopping by dude I appreciate
that well yes a brand new book out does
Glenn Beck addicted to outrage sure to
be a New York Times best seller like all
his other books are this one is really
you can tell a labor of love first of
all it's longer than a lot of your other
and saying well really covers an
enormous amount of ground what prompted
you to write this book in the first
place uh the last four years probably
you know I I mean Ben we've talked about
this before I I kind of went into a
depression of my job is to make sense
the world and my job is to point to the
exits there here here and here and I
couldn't point to the exits anymore I
didn't understand the world we were
living in anymore
and people that asks ok so ok what do we
do what do we do I
got to a point to when you know there's
a hundred and twenty different genders I
don't know cuz I don't know where this
is even coming from and so you know four
years ago I'm thinking okay I just don't
want to do this anymore cuz I don't know
I don't have an answer
started doing my homework started doing
some research started thinking
differently and really started to bone
up on post-modernism and what's really
happening where's where is this coming
from
once you find that and you see what the
goal is of just straight-up
deconstruction I can't think of a
positive thing of post-modernism not one
it's all about taking apart the Western
Way of life and anything that that came
out of the Enlightenment it's really hey
everybody let's go back to the Dark Ages
literally would you agree I think
there's interested in yeah so I can't
think of I can't think of a positive in
that how do you sell that positively so
when you start to understand that you
understand that there is no truth there
is no meaning at cetera et cetera you
start to understand maybe suicide rates
you start to understand why people are
arguing back and forth why people feel
betrayed why people feel like you're a
hypocrite wait you were just saying this
yesterday it's all post-modernism once
you know that now what and so I've spent
the last couple of years and a solid
year hiding that effect that's the
second time I wrote that book just
trying to say okay so now that we know
that we know their goal is chaos how do
we defuse that how do we take it apart
and we're going at it at 180 degrees
around right do you think that the
actual goal of the postmodernist is
cancer do you think it's just a natural
byproduct of their ideology meaning that
to kind of steal man the case for
post-modernism basically what they would
say is that we're all individuals who
operate with certain linguistic sort of
limitations we operate in our own world
there's no such thing as a universal
truth there's just your truth or my
truth there's just my logic and your
logic and we need to acknowledge that so
we can build a new world based on a
subjective objective views of the world
that might be better than the
patriarchal or that has been put in
place so I think that's a real
charitable viewpoint of it I think if
you go back to the roots of what's being
taught now you go back to the 1960s and
the Paris riots where we're not making
we cannot destroy culture we they
thought they had it they had the Beatles
they thought they had all of the culture
they had the hippie movement everything
was going their way that it fell apart
because they didn't have all of the
levers to take Western culture down okay
and again it's it's almost like what
they learned at the Frankfurt School the
people in the West they you know they
they would describe us as they're being
bought off they're being bribed they're
not gonna rise up because they're being
hypnotized brainwashed with their cars
and their products and everything else
they're not going to be the workers of
the world unite and tear it down
so when you look at it from that point
of view from the groups that got
together in the 50s and then again in
the 60s after the Paris riots you then
see that come and jump over here with
the expressed plan of being a virus and
to take down the Western Way of life so
is is that can I mean I guess the
opposition would say maybe that's
conspiratorial thinking is it motivated
or is it just the way that things happen
like are these people stating their case
no I think there's see this is the
problem you know and there's no nuance
in today's world anymore and that leaves
us in a world of black and white and
that's not the way things are there
there are those that look at
post-modernism as some of the founders
did of this particular strain of the
movement that want to tear it apart
because they are Marxist revolutionaries
okay
there are others that look at this you
know for literature and to be able to
understand it etc etc they don't
necessarily have the same goals in fact
I know professors who actually were
Marxist until recently and and one of
them is a guy who was postmodern
literature and felt that there was
meaning in there until recently now he
sees wait a minute the extreme is taking
the the wheel here
it's not those of us who are like now
there's some real meaning here but it's
the extreme and the extremes are the
ones that are or have have control so
there's a lot in your title here
addicted to outrage I want to start with
the first word and then we'll get to the
we'll skip the conjunction then we'll
get to the noise so the the first word
addicted you know you talk in the book
about the idea that we have actually
created an addiction to the feeling that
we get the sort of emotional high that
we get from ripping other people down
and feeling outraged and feeling and
feels good so can you describe that
first of all and also can you talk about
your background with addiction that
actually allows you to sort of shape
this sure okay so let's start with the
addiction we know I've talked to
programmers and and code writers for
Facebook and Google and everything else
they all will tell you if they're honest
we wrote this with all the bells and
whistles and we looked at each other and
how can we get people to spend more time
with us okay everybody does that it's
it's not a bad thing it's Cable News is
doing that what do I do to get you to
watch for another five minutes
so the device that we have now you know
Facebook Twitter all of these things
that we have you know the the the slang
word dope comes from dopamine a hit that
is naturally provided to us that we get
that makes us feel good there's all
kinds of these drugs that are in us that
are natural and addictive and you know
when you're when you're not getting them
you start to become depressed when you
are getting you're feeling good every
time you get a like every time you get a
retweet every time you hear a buzz or a
ding you get a dopamine hit you somebody
likes me
okay the entire country used to say
these people in the media all they're do
it they're only doing these things
because they want the clicks still
people will say that but no one is
saying what are you because why are you
saying this you're saying this because
you want your tweet or your Facebook
post to take off as well you're doing it
for the clicks as well and because we
keep getting this constant
positive reinforcement of the negative
that we put out call them a name you'll
get more dopamine we become addicted to
those that rush and it feels good
without the addiction it's still fun it
kind of feels good for conservatives
because no one has ever hit back for us
and when you have been beaten and beaten
and beaten for so long and you think
that the Western world is under attack
and everything that you hold dear and
it's gonna go away
you look for somebody if you've tried it
all play all over the fairways you look
for somebody who's gonna come in and
just go I'm gonna take you by the scruff
of the neck and I'm gonna take you out
back and beat the snot out of you that's
a problem because that adds to the chaos
of our society we abandon our principles
and principles are all we have if you
look at if you look at Kavanagh what's
happening with with Kavanagh let's not
talk about whether she's telling the
truth or he's telling the truth let's
step back a bit and look at that and say
look people on the right are calling her
name's people on the left are calling
him names we're not going to get
anywhere and all that's doing is
reinforcing to each side we're right and
they're the enemy and the more you get
aggravated and outraged by it the harder
you dig in because you're too vested in
that now I'm going to believe her till
the end of time I'm gonna believe him
till the end of time meanwhile we miss
the principle you know better than most
look there's there's criminal law
there's civil law and then those things
are based on our society what do we want
as people that we think is fair what do
we what do we really believe is justice
we've had a criminal court system that
hasn't been just for a long time back
and forth you know it's got its problems
still I think it's one of the best in
the world but it has its problems no one
no one if you take politics out if you
take the Supreme Court justice or the
Democratic charges take that all out and
I come to you and say then how do you
feel about living in a country where
someone could make an accusation not
know the facts have zero evidence
it's 37 years later the the people that
she did tell the one tells a slightly
different story and at the critical
point in your career at the the eleventh
hour someone can make a charge and call
you a rapist and we have to decide now
whether you're a rapist whether you can
have a job whether you're going to be in
society or not just based on do we like
her or you better
which one's gonna perform better on TV
what do you think is that a fair society
is that a dress horrible why aren't we
talking about that that's that's we are
we are arguing over these little things
while the big principles are just
crumbling nobody wants to live in that
society last night in LA I had a
conversation with a guy who you would
definitely know everybody in the
audience would know who is a very left
guy he sat in our apartment here well
who her eating dinner I had dinner with
a couple of friends and he came in he
said I can't keep up with my own side
I'm constantly on the outs now because I
can't keep up with them and you have to
100% buy into all of it this is
dangerous
this is dangerous when you have people
who are prominent on the left saying I
think I need to say something that tells
you that the absolute crazies are in
control and the average person doesn't
want any part of it
so as I was asking before so your own
addiction and your background in the
past some people may not have heard that
story and I think it does lend some
color to your talking about you know the
dopamine hits in the addiction that
we're all experienced so you know I my
mom died when I was
really young and this kind of took my
life and turned it around and I had been
working in radio when I was 13 and so I
had this really bad toxic mixture of
kind of being like you but you've
conquered this apparently he I became a
monster because everybody was like oh my
gosh look how great he's gonna be
imagine when he's 30 you know you heard
all that I became I bought it and I
became a monster and and I hated myself
and I started drinking and smoking pot
every day was 15 years old every day
until I was 30 and 30 years old my life
completely falls apart it was my 30th
birthday and I remember looking at the
alarm clock and it was about to turn
midnight and it was the day of those old
digital clocks where the numbers kind of
floated almost you know and I saw it
turn midnight and I said to myself your
life is about to change and I didn't
know how yet but I it took me three
years to finally admit that I was an
alcoholic cuz I was a very
high-functioning alcoholic most people
didn't even know I was plowed all the
time and and so that that's not what an
alcoholic is an alcoholic is somebody
who's lost all their money and and
they're you know a wino in the streets
it's not an alcoholic is but I and every
day I would get up and I'd look at
myself in the mirror and I would say
you're pathetic you said this time
yesterday that you wouldn't drink today
and what did you do I know I know I got
not today not today
sometime in the day I found a very
reasonable excuse to start drinking and
doing drugs so I did next day say the
same thing in America got so bad that I
couldn't look at myself in the mirror
anymore every time I would go into the
bathroom any place if there was a mirror
I either didn't use the sink or I opened
the mirror so I couldn't see myself my
daughter came
down my two daughters had breakfast with
me and I was having blackouts and you
know it's not you know in the movies
they make that funny and charming oh did
we do that no it's not funny and
charming you know your your body is on
Isla autopilot and shut everything else
down or it's gonna die
you know I mean and so I was having
blackouts which will freak you out and
my kids came down for breakfast one
morning and they were sitting there and
they said dad tell us the story of inky
blinky and stinky again and that was a
story of three little mice that go to
the island of cheese that I just made up
every night and and I realized not only
could I not remember the story I don't
remember even putting them to bed
I didn't remember being with them at all
and I sat there in such shame and I
thought what are you doing and I lied to
my kids and I said I remember the story
but do you remember the story and as I
fought back the tears over breakfast as
they were telling me the story all I'm
thinking is you got a stop and so I I
went to AAA and I was in the basement of
this church in Connecticut I lived in a
nice neighborhood and none of the people
look like alcoholics you know they're
all successful looking there was this
old lady that was sitting right in front
of me she had a sweater set and pearls
and you know Selma diamond is no okay
she was a great comedy writer in
television years ago and early radio but
she was hysterical and she you remember
Night Court yes okay
she was the bailiff never the woman that
taught me is that woman
sounded like Selma diamond okay and and
she's this beautiful old woman in a
sweater set in pearls and I stand up and
I said hi my name is Glenn and I think I
don't know if I'm an alcoholic and it
really kind of laughed and somebody said
what why why do you feel that way I mean
you're here pretty good indication and I
said well because I died you don't look
like alcoholics
without even turning around she said oh
honey we are all drunks in this room
that one comment gave me permission that
you can still be out of control in your
life and not be in the gutter and I
don't know why that was so hard for me
but I think in a way it's the same thing
we're having here we don't we know our
lives everything in our country is out
of control every day we look and we say
I'm gonna get off Facebook I'm gonna get
off Twitter it's just too ugly
I don't want we're doing it what's the
difference we are addicted the companies
are designing it for us to be addicted
we want that yeah in our life we all
know this isn't good the only difference
here is I can't think of a good reason
to drink
we're excusing it because we're standing
up for our country and no one wants to
surrender in the most important fight
maybe in the history of all mankind so
how do we fight and fight the addiction
at the same time yeah we're gonna talk a
little bit about that and I want to get
to the other half of the title how about
outrage but first let's talk about
getting life insurance so September is
national life insurance Awareness Month
if you listen to this show then you've
heard me talk about how important life
insurance is because here's the thing
you're gonna plot all of you 100 percent
of you will buy sorry to break it to you
I know it's a real downer but that means
you should probably be prepared for that
eventuality by making sure that your
family is not left without anything
here's the thing 40% of Americans still
don't have life insurance so if anything
were to happen to your to you your
family could be left in a really
difficult financial situation these days
there's not really an excuse for not
having it life insurance rates are at a
20-year low it's easier than ever to buy
it especially if you use policy genius
policy genius is the easy way to get
life insurance online in just two
minutes
you can compare quotes from the top
insurers to find the best policy for you
and when you compare quotes you save
money it's that simple policy genius has
helped over 4 million people shop for
insurance they've placed over twenty
billion dollars in coverage and they
don't just do life insurance they also
do disability insurance renter's
insurance health insurance if you care
about it they've got insurance for you
so if you're looking for a good reason
to buy life insurance there are at least
three it's national
Insurance Awareness Month rates heard
it's one of your low and policy genius
makes it easy to get the right policy
for you just go to policy genius comm
get quotes apply in minutes you do the
whole thing right now on your phone
policy genius is the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance
okay so Glenn so I totally agree about
the addiction I myself am a social media
addict I'm particularly a Twitter attic
it is it is varied legitimate Lee over
the weekend I thought I'm gonna remove
Twitter from my phone I'm just gonna
take it off my phone because I go in my
computer far less frequently than I have
my phone on me and it's a weekend I'm
walking around my kids and I'm still
checking the news checking the news just
trying to check Twitter my wife so I
just delete it off your phone I did and
then five hours later I put it back on
the phone because obviously you gotta
know what's going on in the news no it's
very very difficult especially if you
run a news website so that's my
experiment that I run a news website but
I totally agree we are all addicted to
social media addicted to being in the
moment and it's and what that means I
used to think that it was the most
informed people in America who were
gonna save the country and I've started
to think maybe it's the least informed
people in America who are gonna save the
country because we those of us were the
most informed or busy smacking each
other across the head yeah on a routine
basis yeah but that brings us to the
second half of the title outrage so when
we talk about how outraged we are at
each other some outrage obviously is
legit some outrage is not how do you
distinguish which outrage is is
legitimate and which outrage well
there's a there's a couple things first
of all let's go back to Cavanaugh do you
really think that that the Democrats
believe the woman who was was saying
this about Cavanaugh because if you did
why'd you hold on to it for weeks why
you why did you do it at the 11th hour
why didn't you when she insists the FBI
was involved in right away well you know
if it was about her not the process you
would have handled it differently there
are so many things that people are
absolutely outraged about I the what I
quote in the book is the the border been
you know me I was at the board yep when
Obama was putting those people into the
cages taking the children my thing was
they're not only taking away from their
families they're separating the children
so a group of children come their
brothers and sisters well you're ten
you're seven you go in that
cage and you're in this building oh my
gosh can you imagine being a seven year
old girl and separated from your brother
in another country how horrible the
homeland secure the the the the Border
Patrol agents were coming to me and
saying can you get the press to even
listen to this I'm telling you this is
horrible
no I can't get the press I can't get the
breasts I tried I called everybody in
the press no one cared your own side
killed you for it and my own side killed
me for it you know but courage doesn't
count when you take on your enemies Curt
Schilling counts when you stand up to
your friends ago brother come on you're
better than this so nobody would listen
to it then all of a sudden they discover
a picture taken from that time period
and they're morally outraged they just
can't take it then they are like oh oh
crap okay make excuse make excuse oh
well look at what's happening now okay
well how about the separation of the
kids how about that one is anyone
talking to you about how they're taking
brothers and sisters and still
separating them and the trauma that that
might cause no they don't care they have
one line they didn't care then they only
care right now because it's political
expediency on top of that what's the
answer the answer the answer is you must
stop the chaos at the border which means
you have to go to the countries and say
we as the United States of America want
to make it really clear every single
person that comes across our border will
go home period do not send your kids if
you are a refugee if there is something
going on there is a system go to the
United States Embassy here are the
things that we look for for refugee
status we are a nation that brings
refugees in for safety we have every
intention of continuing that for real
refugees no more chaos that's the way
you fix it but nobody's interested
fixing it you are people really outraged
by the shooting in parkland are they
really outraged by it or are they seeing
an opportunity to divide us on the on
the on the one subject for that and
abortion we're not changing okay half of
the country and abortion is even weaker
than this the Second Amendment is the
Second Amendment to a good number of
people in the country good number of
people don't care about guns they want
to change it it's not going anywhere
our children are at risk actually as the
book points out we're not the lowest
shootings the you know school shootings
I think in the last 30 years it's
delicous yeah that's rapid decline safer
when it was safer now than it was in the
90s or the 80s in schools so if but if
you really cared we would do something
about it if the parents in Parkland I
and I just asked one of the parents this
just recently they didn't give me an
answer I mean no disrespect but if I was
a parent in the Parkland School District
I would have and I didn't believe in
guns I would have said been doing the
thing about guns but I also would have
demanded the resignation of the sheriff
I would have demanded a change at the
school board I would have demanded
changes at the school they haven't done
any of that
so is this really about children dying
or is this about politics I I can't have
like I can't like I don't want to be a
part of a society that's using things
that are so stop using our emotions stop
playing on our emotions
it's either real or it's not they
accused me of playing on people's
emotions when I said the Caliphate was
coming look what happened there are
things that you can look at because
you'll take people at their word and say
no they really mean it they're gonna try
to do this and you can warn people
that's not preying on their on their
their mo
that is just telling the truth and
saying I think if you look at these
things two plus two equals four I think
this is where we're headed the other is
I'm just gonna say these things because
I can twist them into that make you feel
like the boogeyman is coming so you run
to me both sides are doing it and it's
it's it's it's gonna be the death of us
but do you think this question of the
sincerity or do you think that it's a
question of people who are legitimately
outraged but for different purposes
meaning that you know it's easy for me
to sit here and say you know if a parent
and parkland really cared they do
something about the the sheriff Scott
Israel totally I agree with that
obviously well what if there's a parent
parkland and they think yeah you know
there's the Scott Israel issue and sure
easy schmuck but I'm much more concerned
that kids all over the country are
really being scared like how do we how
do we decide whether the person's
outrage is legitimate or whether the
person is is being manipulative and is
it possible that you miss reading that
motivation we could be contributing to
part of the problem as well so this is
the problem this is why our system of
government is wholly inadequate for
immoral and irreligious people okay you
know people are trying to tear down
capitalism first of all capitalism has
high outline extensively in the book has
changed the world I mean this is the
greatest time even with all of our
problems Donald Trump and Barack Obama's
America the best time and the best place
to be alive in all of human history
so please pipe down but you look at
capitalism and you say capitalism is bad
well that's because you you forgot the
first half Moral Sentiments okay if you
just read Adam Smith's Wealth of Nations
you'll understand the invisible hand but
you will not understand what an immoral
population will do with that invisible
hand it will come and it will choke the
life out of people so you have to be a
decent people I still believe that most
Americans right and left are decent not
all never but they're decent they don't
want to destroy somebody else and they
don't want to you know my way or the
highway I don't want any Jews or black
Sorkin's
serve it is or liberals or homosexuals
or or cisgender whatever they don't want
that I just want to live next to each
other and raise their families don't
tell me what to do
I won't tell you what to do let's just
let's just live our life we have to
return to that cuz I can't tell you
who's telling you the truth and who's
not who's really outraged I know that
there's two things on outraged going on
right now some people are not outraged
and I would I would say that if it's
involved in politics its most likely not
true
then there are the people that are
absolutely true that worthy I got to
give him a trophy I have to give him a
ribbon everybody wins Oh everybody's so
special that are just coming out of
college now they actually believe that
they're outraged they really are
outraged but those people need to be
told you got to get over it
you got to get you got to get a life
because what you know as Jonathan hight
says in his new book coddling of
American mind you have your parents and
society has prepared the road for you
that's not reality they should have
prepared you for the road and what makes
us what doesn't what what doesn't kill
us makes us stronger but right now we
live in a society that says the opposite
what doesn't kill you makes you weaker
and we got to avoid all of that stuff
no no so I want to talk to you in one
second about the application of of your
principle how people on the Left have
responded to you trying to out stretch
your hand and how well that's going but
first first I want to tell you about
Robin Hood it's an investing app that
lets you buy and sell stocks ETFs
options and Kryptos all commission-free
they strive to make Financial Services
work for everyone not just for rich
folks who can afford a financial advisor
it's a non intimidating way for stock
market newcomers to invest for the first
time with true confidence it is simple
and intuitive I've looked at the app it
works great it's clearly designed with
data presented in an easy to digest way
other broker
can charge up to ten bucks for every
trade but Robin Hood doesn't charge any
Commission fees he trade stocks and you
keep all the profits it's easy to
understand they have charts and market
data you can place a trade in just four
taps on your smartphone robin hood's web
platform also lets you view stock
collections like the 100 most popular in
sectors like entertainment and they let
you view analyst ratings of buy hold
sell for every single stock learn how to
invest as you built your portfolio as
well so your beginner well it's a good
time for you to start figuring out if
this is something even want to do well
Robin Hood can let you do that discover
new stocks track favorite companies with
personalized news feeds customize
notifications for price movements I mean
it feels complex when I talk about it it
is not when you actually look at it
that's how well-designed this app is
Robin Hood is giving listeners a free
stock like Apple for Sprint's to help
you build your portfolio sign up right
now at Ben Robin Hood com that's been
dot Robin Hood calm once more Ben that
Robin Hood calm okay Glen so you've that
I'm sure the number one question you're
gonna get asked about this book is here
you're saying that we are addicted to
outrage but you're Glenn Beck right like
that that's I'm sure this is the
question that you're gonna get most
frequently particularly from folks on
the Left aren't you that guy who was
doing chalkboard signs and you and you
talk in the book a little bit about you
know what you think of those days and
where you think you're right and where
you think you're wrong so let me ask you
what do you think was right and what do
you think was wrong there I think I was
right on the direction I mean you know
pretty much everything that I was
writing all those chalkboards yeah
pretty much it's happened where I was
was wrong but I want to put it into
context was possibly the presentation my
job if I what you work at Fox what's
your job at Fox I mean to get ratings
presumably correct to get ratings if you
don't get ratings how long are you gonna
last now long okay that's what they hire
you for get ratings and because I know
who you are and you know who I am tell
the truth okay as you perceive it
I am a I'm an entertainer okay I grew up
as a kid listening to Orson Welles I
mean I love theater of the mind I love
it I know how to stunts I know how I can
take a live frog you know cut
tape replace it with a plastic frog
throw it in boiling boiling water and
it'll set the world on fire but people
are watching because they see that
they'll also hear the truth my problem
was I honestly believed that so naive I
was I honestly believed that if I could
get members of the press to actually
hear on a day after day basis facts real
facts honest questioning saying look
don't trust me I was saying this for the
press as much as the average individual
do not take my word for it look this up
for yourself I'm begging the press look
it up for yourself this is not crazy
conspiracy talk this is what's happening
right now and you don't have to condemn
it but we should recognize it and answer
for it they don't care they don't care
and I there's it's it's they've gone
dead inside you can talk to people about
some of the bigger concepts you know of
of what we're facing none of them know
what they're talking about
none of them their eyes just glaze over
they're not intellectually curious they
think their responsibility is to pair it
whatever it is the party is saying and I
I saw this on both sides I mean I worked
at CNN and Fox I know both of them
inside and out
it's not that different it's not that
different it at Fox I had pure
independence you know they tried to do
things but you know I was smart enough
to set up my contract the way it was but
it's all about parties it's all about
parties and and when I left there you
can't be I went from the third or fourth
most admired man in the world think of
that I mean I remember when I saw that
ap does that that survey every year I
was I was between
Nelson Mandela and I think I was
actually not between them
it was Nelson Mandela me and the Pope
tied for third or fourth place me in the
poll
okay and I my family I we read they were
like this is hysterical
okay how off-center is America when I'm
even near that when I'm handing that
list to somebody the very next year one
of the most hated men in America I
didn't change anything
I changed networks I did the same show
on CNN as I did on Fox
I changed networks and that's what
happens wait a minute time goes on
you're getting beaten as badly as I was
beaten and called all kinds of names
your children my children were accosted
in the park several parks many different
states from Alaska to Hawaii to New York
the park experience you say parked any
of my kids and they're like no let's not
go to work so you can't go into that
position and then not say which guy am i
I know I'm not Nelson Mandela in the
Pope so dismiss that I'm not that guy
either and it's easy to say well that's
the media that's the media for you
that's George Soros for you hmm
no that's part of it and a big part of
it but I played a role in that too and
the role I played was not recognizing
the time that we were in
not knowing how high the stakes were of
the people I was playing against you
know you're not going to win and so
playing you know being in lederhosen and
you know doing all the crazy things that
we did I don't regret any of it I don't
regret really almost anything I said
even the president being a racist if you
read the book last night we clarified it
in like the next scent it makes sense to
you sure yeah and and and if you don't
know I was very similar things I said
very similar things of it right and and
what I said was he's racist well no he's
not he just has a real deep-seated
hatred for the white culture well I
couldn't verbalize it at the time since
2008 I know I've got Jeremiah Wright
sitting out there who doesn't like the
white culture doesn't like America the
the history of America so but what is
that is that racism no no it's actually
post-modernism it's it's all of this
crap that's out there and so when you're
asking me is he racist that was what i
grabbed at just like i think people are
grabbing at Donald Trump's a racist
trump's not a racist he's not a racist I
don't think what he is or what I should
say what people like Don Lemon I think
and I don't know I have not talked to
Don about this but to give him the
benefit of the doubt let's reverse the
roles I just went through this okay you
didn't understand because I didn't
understand what I was trying to say
somebody is he's got this thing where he
wants to deconstruct the Western Way of
life all the people around him want to
deconstruct okay he's a postmodernist
he's not racist postmodernist okay what
Don fails to see and really kind of what
I failed to see during the the last
election was people feel you know when
you're in where is it Norway I think are
Sweden you can't fly the Swedish flag
anymore if you fly the Swedish flag I
think it's Sweden you will be called a
racist because you have to fly the EU
flag well no
when I went to Sweden a couple years ago
I've talked to somebody they said well
you know it's nothing special I said
this isn't special have you been a
Copenhagen you've been to Sweden before
now okay go
is there like gingerbread houses it's
the greatest architect it's completely
unique completely different it is really
cool and is it there I was on the street
with somebody I said you don't see how
unique this is don't be ashamed of your
culture your history this is great and
you can't find it anywhere else it
doesn't mean it's better than anything
else it just means it is different be
proud of your culture you can't do that
well people want that they're proud of
where we came from what we struggled
through we should be ashamed of the
appropriate things in our history that
we're ashamed of but you can't just
erase all of that so when people are
saying hey my culture matters what
people on the left here is racist you're
trying to erase my past and my heritage
oh you like slavery no that's not what
I'm saying
but that's what people on the Left
associate so when Don Lemon says well he
likes racists because look at the
language he's using you know the culture
is being erased
you know our heritage is important yes
it is but it means different things to
different people so back away from the
cliff and let's try to understand each
other's language and then we can give
them each other yes but but but do it on
actual tangible things truth so in the
last few years you've been saying a lot
of things that are honest because you're
really honest guy or emotionally open
guy and an honest guy and that's ticked
off a lot of people on your own side
how's that been number one and number
two what's the response of people on the
Left bin to the quote-unquote new Glenn
Beck the kind of attempts to reach
across the aisle and have discussions
because I can imagine that while you are
opening a or you're putting out an open
hand I can't imagine that in every case
certainly not publicly there are people
who are actually taking it
Oh publicly no the worst
the most shameful on the last left I
think is glad I went to go see the
president of gladden and her crew she
came into my office in New York City and
and I called for the meeting and I said
I just leave here arms at home and can
we just come and talk and I started the
meeting I said look everyone everyone on
my side will hate me for this will hate
me for this I don't agree with anything
that you guys do okay
I think you're a very militant group
however right now in Russia they are
abusing homosexuals abducting them
killing them taking their driver's
license away this is at the time what
five years ago it was getting really
ugly in Iran they're throwing
homosexuals off the rooftops of
buildings people need to be brave and
people need to say look then in our case
it's not that wide but I need I need
Penn Jillette to be able to stand next
to the Pope and have both of them say
look there's a lot of huge things we
disagree with but there's a couple of
principles that we do and and for GLAAD
and Glenn back to stand next to each
other and saying killing homosexuals is
wrong we've just taken a big chip off
the table of both sides okay
we've lowered the temperature and we can
talk spend an hour showing them the
picture showing them the news of all
around the world where we could agree
all they wanted to talk about were birth
were wedding cakes and I got so
frustrated I said do
wedding cakes or saving the lives of
people they cared about wedding cakes I
have decided that if you're in politics
I don't know
I'm not going to you for honest
brokering somebody I came out here to LA
and somebody very big VC guy had
listened to me what at one point and I
went into a conference about a thousand
people they're all lefties all high-tech
and I started my speech at twenty
minutes and I said let me just start
here raise your hand and don't be shy
and they weren't raise your hand if you
think you hate me literally ninety five
ninety eight percent okay everybody and
I was like okay well you're not shy
give me twenty minutes and I never
changed the principle I used Jonathan
Heights book of the of the the righteous
mind okay I just started to speak their
language okay without changing my
principles and I did the most important
thing any of us can do start with an
apology or some place where you got it
wrong okay I did at the end I think it
was only my family that was raising
their head III asked the same thing and
it was maybe five percent it was an
exact flip of the room in 20 minutes and
that's only because I'm I'm trying to
hear them my mistake during the Trump
run up I became so strident because I
was certain who he was well as it turns
out he is in some wet degrees who I
thought he was or worse in some ways
he's a miracle okay you know he is both
sides but I was so positive that he
would have nothing good and I wasn't
listening to people we we used to
respect people we don't respect them
anymore and and that is stopping us from
doing what
people who respect each other then I
know if you walk down the hall and you
start cussing people out that's so
unlike you that somebody will say then
is something going on what's going on
right mm-hmm
so America starts acting irrationally
start going in a direction they've
always said they would never go and I
didn't say what's happening what is
happening in your life
it's why the media is still missing the
Trump voters they're unwilling to ask so
so what is it and listen and accept the
answer may not be the answer you're
looking for but it is the answer live in
the world you you actually live in or
live in some fantasy world but I choose
to live in the world that's actually
existing listen to people so you talked
a lot about in the book outrage in the
culture about then you talk about you
know the serious problems that outrage
is preventing us from discussing I'm
gonna ask about those important
questions but first let's talk about
genes quality genes that look great look
at this thing fit great feel great used
to cost you hundreds of bucks Mott and
beau has permanently changed the game
with $200 designer jeans for half the
price they're super comfortable I know
I'm sitting in them right now
introducing Matt and beau calm or you
can get the most comfortable premium
jeans you will ever wear for half what
you'd pay elsewhere for a G or seven
jeans these are luxury jeans for a
hundred bucks and you can only get them
at Matt and Bo com
they are the most comfortable because
these the best and comfort technology
like dynamic stretch and they are
premium because they only source their
denim from two of the most well
respected denim mills in the world to
make sure your jeans fit you perfectly
they have an at-home Tryon program you
request a second pair with your order
you try it both you keep one you send
the other back in the same box with a
prepaid label so check out their top
styles and cuts on Mott and Bo calm and
with their at home Tryon program sending
you two pair of times you can find the
perfect fit for your body business
insider says this about montón bo guys
these are the most comfortable jeans you
will ever wear they are super
comfortable again I'm wearing them I
know these are $200 designer jeans for
half the price plus they have a
September savings event which means you
will save 20% on everything at Matt and
Bo comm / Ben that's MOT tea and Bo w
comm / Ben for 20% off everything this
is their best deal anywhere by
it is only available this month save 20%
sorry Mont and both September savings
event at Mott and Bo calm / Ben okay so
Glen you talk in the book I want to tell
you I I understand why steven crowder
didn't wear pants it is the fires a hell
hot in here oh yeah
how are you wearing it listen I'm
wearing a jacket because you're wearing
a jacket I thought I was going to attack
because you're wearing a jacket may I
turn up the heat so that it looks like
I'm really grilling yeah I don't start
sweating Richard Nixon in 1960 I can see
was oh my all that questioning but you
know you talk here about you know the
fact that we're engaged with outrage and
I've said on my program a thousand times
that as you say we're living in the best
time in human history if you could be
born any time you'd want to be born
right now right now but we're angry at
each other but we are because of that
anger missing some really deep problems
so what are the deep problems not just
the outrage culture what are the deep
problems we're missing that we're gonna
have to figure out solutions for over
the next 10-15 years so I lay out about
I don't know five or 10 of them that I
think are are we're absolutely going to
have to deal with from anywhere from
what is life you know is is a AI Agia si
is that going to claim to be life and
will we accept that you know they just
turned a sex robot around at the
Canadian border from Japan you can't
import sex robots that look like
children okay
so you have a sex robot is that good for
pedophiles could we could it would it be
good to have them get it out on a robot
or is that bad
discussions going on nobody knows about
it how about the I think it's called the
smart machine I can't remember it's MIT
is doing it and it's online and they're
asking you to go online and just take
some quizzes and what this quiz is is
the value of life you're in a car it's
an auto drive you're in the car and
there's a car in front of you it's just
and on the brakes if you swerve this way
you're gonna hit none and two kids
if you swerve this way you're gonna go
into the you're gonna go into the the
other sidewalk and you're gonna hit a
whole bunch of kids and puppy dogs if
you go straight
you're gonna hit Elon Musk and Steve
Jobs okay what do you do now they're
asking people online okay
then the rest of the you know brilliant
elites are programming based a little
bit of what's online and the debate
that's going on right now that we're not
a part of here's the problem the
computer in the car will know who's in
the car in front of you but as it says
in this survey it can know who they are
what they do what they contribute to
society how many if any they employ how
many benefits they're getting from the
government how their health is it can
calculate all of that as it makes a
decision well now there now there is no
random strike now we are saying who's
worth something and who's not Bain
Capital came out few months ago said by
2030 we will have 30% unemployment that
is the Great Depression here's the thing
it's permanent unemployment there is no
going back we have a society right now
that is saying hey look at the job
numbers look how low unemployment slow
historic lows will you have Silicon
Valley right now working on devices and
algorithms and machines that are are
their goal is 100 percent unemployment
so what is what gives your life meaning
what does that mean when that transition
starts to hit what do you do with the
people who the truck drivers are going
to be the first mover driver's cab
drivers truck drivers are the first what
happens when
that's displaced because in most states
number-one job truck driving so how many
people does that affect what do you do
for civil society the the universal
basic income something I don't believe
in but what do we do about that is that
right for the future we can't have a
universal basic income conversation
because to a conservative that sounds
like socialism not capitalism socialism
we don't want socialism we don't want
communism but the world is changing so
how do we bring our guard down bring
their guard down and actually talk about
it without bringing politics into it and
see what is what is right on top of that
you have radicalized Islam you have the
the mullahs in Iran who are dead set on
destroying Israel they believe in
something called the 12th Imam the Mahe
which is if they say is living among us
now he's like you know our he's like our
Jesus if you will not your Jesus who's
coming back at the end of days but this
one can be brought back by washing the
world in blood and causing chaos the
reason why I bring that up chaos is the
operative word and I said this when I
was on Fox the word that you need to
look for and then you need to be aware
of is chaos if what you're doing is
causing chaos you are going to be part
of the problem they're looking for chaos
guy named Alexander Dugan in Russia only
one reporter in the Washington Post is
on this guy nobody is on this guy he has
started something called the world
national conservative movement this is a
this is a fascistic movement based on
what he calls the fourth political
theory the symbol of his fourth
political theory is the ancient symbol
of chaos he believes literally we have
to go through Armageddon to be able to
reset the world
then you have the the Marxists
revolutionaries here that want to reset
the world and reset the West and then
start all over again
we're being pulled by all these forces
of chaos and nobody's recognizing it
we're arguing on the smallest little
things that don't matter
wedding cakes shut up about wedding
cakes how about the bigger principles
we've got to get back to the bigger
principles so that's my final question
for you which is what are those bigger
principles that we have to unify around
like well we're - where do we unify
around this I'm gonna ask you that but
that is our final question and if you
want to hear Glenn's answer you actually
have to be a daily wire subscriber see
that's how we pitch - go check that out
right evil capitalist look at that -
subscribe go to daily we're calm and
click subscribe you can hear the end of
our conversation there and otherwise
it's a girl we're gonna leave you in
this abysmal darkness so it's all up to
you Gwen well what are these values that
we need to sense her around this is
where you should cut it right after the
sentence I've spent four years trying to
figure that one out here's the answer
well the book is addicted to outrage
Glenn Beck one of the foremost thinkers
in the country Glenn thanks so much for
stopping by really appreciate you
[Music]
the venture Pierrot shows Sunday special
is produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy borin associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex Singaram audio is
mixed by Mike Carr Amina hair and makeup
is by jess wa al vera and title graphics
by Cynthia and Gullu ben shapiro shows
sunday special is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018
[Music]